don't bring anyone love into this we
will catch you up on something that's
been it's rolling into this week a few
weeks ago somebody sent us this guy who
walking down the street decided he was
gonna write a song into camera and it
there wasn't a lot going on in the song
he just trying to sing my song trying to
see my song okay here we go here we go
I'm another beat down for you try to
practice practice my own song this my
production to my song coming out you
know here we go I'll see it she's
retarded she's within change was then
they got a gun and got again yeah I got
a gun terminating a gun yeah machines
broke this machine's worth in T 16 T 16
trying to rank my rep trying to make my
rep John fuck so much
machines you can't tell me you don't
like they don't ya like a little bit I
can tell he's like if dj khaled was
actually dumber so we knew it what
happened we get we get of all the
podcasts the most amazing song
submissions so last week how that was
made specifically for your show so but
we know that like whenever we play like
you know we play like she's retarded
clip yeah like someone will make a song
out of that sound like some of them are
legit song predict production people you
know they'll just
[Music]
this is a certified classic I've been
having machines within stuck in my head
that's two genes with it you though
right sounds like a vibrator store yeah
it it it's incredible and more machines
within came in this here's a young
yeah the terminate again let's see what
this one is here
[Music]
it's on now
incredible that's amazing
this is a by the way this is machines
with in metal by machine
they made a real did like he put a band
together and no so what happens is like
okay so for like the first few what
happened was people took the audio that
we played of this guy walking down the
street just means within and they
created a song out of that in other
words they they looped in beats and yeah
and they and they made a song out right
this one right here I don't know if on
that one right there they actually sang
it themselves or well they distorted it
or not I don't know it's pretty but like
this guy right here just submitted this
also so here's a little different take
on machines with I mean that's gonna be
the folk on it
big fans saw you guys saw Tom and Indy
and it was an amazing time we kept
singing machines with him all day so
[Music]
that's amazing that's by Kyle she's
within by Kyle so good that's impressive
haters Wow impressive men I mean those
guys inspiring people blown away been
these two how'd I know is gonna be fun
I don't nail that Newt you did nail that
and that's amazing that's my pick Oh God
and they both work yeah that's the thing
these guys found a way to make this song
work it's all about the producer man
it's all about the eye definer well did
you guys put out an album what's a year
no Christmas guys stalling before an
oral exam
crazy this is a what's jeans what's fake
DJ meet farts unbelievable what's how it
CJ meet farts has a good little sound
system yeah that t16 is the Terminator
yeah of course
so someone eroded my husband Stewart is
an avid listener your mom's house he
listens while working he came home the
day machines within episode was played
it's always been singing the song is
stuck in my head I haven't listened to
it it's hard to get down dirty and he's
missing
he seems what it is all I'm hearing
beforehand as a previous writer
submitted that Juggalo has tapped into
something in my husband and now I'm
afraid of my husband is a gonna convert
to Juggalo ISM you guys are an awful
influence to my 27 year old husband
much-loved Christie Christie it's
infected all of us machine has changed
yeah if I do kill multiple people that
will be when I come do you want to know
something that guy posted another video
of a new song yeah duction much love no
hate for Halloween I am the mass
murderer of mayhem mass murderer my song
is called the mass murder of the grave
Oh
so far mass murderer of the grave the
mass murderer of the grave of the grave
as can be mass murderer of the grave as
can be mass murderer makes me it was
great in joke writing you really had to
make your premise clear and that's what
he does with songs yeah he's like the
rock really shuts it up yeah here's what
the songs about well and for people that
aren't watching he has he has blood on
his face in his clubs
I mean way to bury the lead on that
I know we did leave that out because
we're like yeah mass murder on the mass
murder to the grave from the grave to
the grave mass murder from the grave
yeah mass murder from the nra is gonna
be defending this guy soon mass murder
from the grave I'm chopping the first
mass murderer makes me cool mass
murderer makes me cool cool
who can be cool as candy oh my god I
mean how how is it possible this guy is
two for two in the hit me in the grave
mass murderer from the grave I wouldn't
agree experiencing from hell yeah hell
is chaos ask do you think he could do
live do you think he'd do a live show I
think yeah if you could book him as your
opener that's all you're saying yeah I
mean like do you think you could handle
it's a good five minutes
yeah try to get him a shut up once
you're onstage though mass grave as can
wait how did they hear did you play this
in a previous episode somebody found
this man video and made the song next
episode people will have made much mass
murder from the Ray
mass murder from the paper chopping the
first mass murderer makes me who mass
murderer makes me cool
yeah mass murder makes me cool alright
can be my slab no hate much love yes
very similar that is a no chase with
that song thank you no chase thanks
everybody's sending in your machines
within remixes those were really good
looking forward to she's retarded songs
next week really good
[Music]